so welcome back to the iced coffee hour
and we were just talking about this
before filming and i figured we we may
as well just record and talk about this
alex uh alex got in a uh heated
debate i guess
not a disagreement it's not a fight got
in a heated debate with uh his wife
and was asking for
uh my thoughts and i figured well let's
uh let's air this out for everyone here
for your thoughts you aren't you just
want me to air on the air i just give my
thoughts unsolicited but you know what
that's good advice
yeah no one's here yeah this was
prompted because we asked alex what the
biggest fight he's ever had with his
yeah we were talking about relationships
and uh the biggest fights so let me tell
you my biggest fight i guess so um we
were going to go to california and visit
my wife's mom uh she was visiting in
california it's about a four and a half
hour drive and uh before we take off
we're hungry so we grab some food
you know we stop in the car you know
we're gonna just eat real quick um
and i'm using like a like a fork
and my wife asked me like can you can
you sanitize your hands i'm like oh no
i'm good and like she asked me like
like she kept asking me
and uh
i told her to stop
because i was like
that's getting annoying or something
like that and uh she was very hurt and
so uh
she turned away from me you know it was
a it was very heated
and um
i told her i did not want to go to
california
because
there's bad vibes in the air i'm not
gonna sit through a four and a half hour
car ride
to go to california and endure that okay
so i offer for her to take the car i
offer to buy her a plane ticket
um but i i did not want to go my mind
was already set on i do not want to go
so um
you know then we had a conversation
about you know
am i wrong we were only maybe five
minutes into the trip we hadn't left
vegas at all
so uh is it wrong for me
to no longer want to go okay there's a
lot of stuff to break down here so you
were five minutes into the trip what
were you eating
i don't even remember
it was
it was when was that uh two months ago
so it was fairly recent
yeah
why did you
how did it escalate from user hand
sanitizer to
not wanting to just cancelling the
entire trip oh because i i kept getting
bugged about it so she was saying use
hand sanitizer you're like no
yeah because i was like using already
eating first of all and are you guys
sharing no no no it's your food yeah
it's my food and like i'm using a fork
and anyway
the
the whole thing was just like it wasn't
the hand sanitizer part i don't care
about like i use hand sanitizer all the
time
but it was the persistency of after i
persistence
yeah after i say persistent and
consistency yes persistency persistency
that's a word i know it's not is it yes
persistency i'm not going to be the one
to look it up
i've never heard of persistency i it
sounds like it is a word it's a word but
persistence would just be
it's a word wow it is a word yeah the
quality of persisting tenacity yes
you're looking at me as if like
persistency oh my gosh i'm like
persistent and cons okay anyway you're
right so anyway you know after the first
time i was like oh you know i'm okay you
know after the second time i was like no
no like seriously i'm okay
third time i was like can you can you
please just stop
like you were bugged based off of
something else already just
no i was bugged off the fact that
that she kept asking me after i told
like even after the third time i was
like okay was it immediate like do it
and you're like no do it no no no i was
like oh no it was a few minutes i was
like yeah i was in between sure until
the point where i was like the fourth
time i was like all right like seriously
like just leave me alone
like thank you but you said can you
please stop that was your word the third
time that was my like warrant i was like
can you please stop asking me
i was like because i was already a
little peeved she didn't get that mad
you know what that but the one she got
mad at was the fourth one where i was
like like seriously stop it's getting
annoying or whatever i said and then
what did she retort to that
she did the whole
time
i was like you know i wish that we could
have a conversation you know about it
and you know but she was hurt she was
hurt about it and so you know she was
upset
i was annoyed i didn't want to i didn't
want to endure
why did she want the hand sanitizer so
badly let's start there so she's kind of
a germaphobe
but
and i i like i said i normally like
sanitize my hands all the time and stuff
but my thought was like okay i would
understand if like i'm trying to hold
your hand i'm trying to we were sharing
food maybe
um but she just it was bugging her just
because yeah that sounds like a control
thing and it sounds like you're feeding
into her phobia of cleanliness
to a certain degree if it does if it
impacts her i could see it but if it's
if it's you and your food i get why
like i understand your point of view on
that one yeah i mean to me it's just not
that big of a deal if someone was
annoying me to the point of me saying
something like snappy like that i would
be like you know what i'll just use the
hand sanitizer rather than because i
give it i didn't want no you i didn't
want to give in because right here's the
thing it's like yeah then it can go and
it builds resentment it starts with the
hand sanitizer and it's like jack i
don't like that shirt you're wearing put
on another shirt jack no really don't
like that [ __ ] do another [ __ ] check it
out i just don't think that there are
many things in my life that i care about
enough to that extent where it's just
like no it's not the hands i think
you're missing the point like i don't
care about the hand sanitizer it's just
like i just did not want to i don't care
that she even like asked or like the
point was i did i i was so peeved to the
point that i didn't want to go
because
i didn't want to sit through a four and
a half hour car ride not having a single
word to say we because we finished we
ate and we didn't talk and i was let's
be honest you're seeing your in-laws in
california right
what are you trying to say jack you're
trying to get out and trying to get out
of it
that's like a you know
thing that's what she asked me
afterwards and i was like no i was like
there's nothing to do with that i
literally all i wanted to do i just did
not want to sit through a four and a
half hour car ride
you know and feel resentment at me took
from my wife because i
didn't handset but that's sometimes some
of the best spots to be when you're
trapped in a car with somebody for a
while
uh you know
you've had experience with this well
you know it's it's uh it could be it
could be useful to flush out some of
those things it's the most uncomfortable
thing ever but sometimes like forces you
to confront those issues
did you end up going to california um i
think we did yeah you didn't
no i didn't no you didn't oh no no no i
uh no because i worked right yeah um did
kelsey go i like how you have to ask uh
i don't think so yeah i don't think so
either
nobody ended up going yeah we didn't go
we didn't go yeah
so in my opinion i get where you're
coming from it's important for people to
know their places
i would have given in but maybe that's
not the right thing to do i do think
that canceling the entire trip to
california was probably
uh it was probably an overreaction
because realistically the trip had
probably been planned for weeks and this
was something that occurred in you know
five minutes that no i think we planned
it like a week ago
but
the point is that it was something that
had been planned right that was probably
looked you know it was a big commitment
yeah and then something that occurs in
five minutes so and i try to look at
things like that if there's an argument
that occurs and it's a five-minute
argument that can
throw away something that had been weeks
i always look at like okay how much time
are we spending doing this versus how
much time did we get excited over doing
that so we got over the
the pain centers apart pretty easily you
know obviously we we were like
you know
we were both hungry which
obviously affects people's mood um but
on top of that we were like yeah we
should have just you know but the part
that we had a real conversation about
and this is where i want your guys's
opinion um my wife at the time was not
driving as much as she does now so she
felt like i was making the decision for
her not to go
now i didn't want to put her in that
position so i offered you know i'll get
you an uber to the airport i'll buy you
a flight on my dime
do you think that
i i was a little bit too like making the
decision not to go for her i thought i
was being um being accommodating by
trying to help her get to cal you know
because i promised her i would drive her
i no longer want to go but offering to
buy her a flight that's fair you know
yeah so what do you think about that
jack i think that's fair i i don't think
that you're trying to prevent her from
seeing her i think she agreed with that
afterwards as well but now we're all
good guys i don't want yeah i don't want
you guys to think that uh anything's
going on but uh we were just talking
about some some relationship stuff
before and we figured you know maybe you
guys have had a similar experience good
stuff jack i heard that you started a
new business well i didn't hear you told
me you started a new business yes so i
started i'm doing a thing on the side
now so i've always had my stuff and then
we had the mentorship group we cancelled
that out and it freed up a little bit of
time where i can allocate that towards
something else and i got presented with
an opportunity because i know a creator
that doesn't do sponsorships or tried
but wasn't doing them very well
and they have a high upload frequency
and they have plenty of opportunity to
be capitalizing on sponsors and i've
been managing the sponsors for the iced
coffee hour for the past like two years
so i have a lot of experience when it
comes to this and i basically said i
will be your in-house you know sponsor
manager where i won't be sourcing videos
because i have connections with agents
that will source the deals but i'll be
the person that writes the scripts gets
the video editing done deals with
compliance with these companies so
that's basically a lot of the stuff that
has to be done on the back end for each
sponsor shout out ftx and also shout out
aura but first we want to thank our
sponsor aura do you guys want to know
what the fastest growing crime affecting
millions of people in america is well
the answer is identity theft and there's
a new victim every 14 seconds but
thankfully aura is there to help aura is
identity theft protection fraud
monitoring a vpn and anti-virus software
all combined into one easy to use app
those who have had their identity stolen
are often shocked when it happens it's a
scary situation and it's the unfortunate
reality for a lot of people thankfully
though aura monitors the dark web for
your emails passwords and social
security numbers and sends alerts fast
right to your phone and email when i
entered my email into aura they scanned
the dark web and found that my email and
password had been compromised more than
five times i personally dealt with a lot
of identity theft even here on youtube
with people impersonating me to try to
scam people so i've seen firsthand just
how malicious some people could be and
it's not to be taken lightly you can
connect your credit and bank accounts
and you'll get notified of any changes
up to four times faster than ora's
competitors i'm also curious to know how
many of you have had your personal
information leaked on the dark web
because i have a feeling it's going to
be rather surprising so protect your
family and yourself from identity theft
at aura.com
iced coffee down below in the
description and if you sign up today you
can get a free two-week trial with
aura.com iced coffee again the link is
down below in the description for anyone
who wants to get started with aura today
and now with that said let's get back to
the podcast but yeah so i basically
decided to handle all of that to make it
a very seamless and easy experience for
the creator so they can focus all of
their attention to creating content
rather than having it split amongst
creating content dealing with sponsors
editing the sponsors all of that stuff
yeah remember he came to me and asked
and initially i was really hesitant
because i'm like
as long as it doesn't take away from the
iced coffee hour and the second channel
i think anything beyond that it's not
really my my say and uh i want you to do
well but not at the expense of anything
else that we're already doing so it's
like as long as those don't fall to the
sidelines and as long as those like take
the priority then
you know i'm fine with it
i'm really excited about it it's super
cool to have my own control over
something that like
basically is completely detached from
the brand right because if something
ever happens with this god forbid which
i strongly don't think it will um then
i'll have this because they're
completely unrelated and it's doing it
did you put on hand sanitizer
no i didn't do that no
stop it
stop it right let's cancel the podcast
no i'm kidding oh my gosh
anyways should i say how much i made or
do you think that's weird no i'd say
people are gonna be really happy last
month i made seven thousand dollars wow
wow
yeah and i have overhead too which is uh
yeah my 10 cut right yeah yeah right
come on
it was about seven hundred dollars it
was exactly 700 bucks so my 10 yeah but
it's cool i mean the thing is i'm
employing skills that i've had for a
long time and i have a competitive
advantage in this because i've been
doing it for such a long time uh and it
works so yeah yeah you just have to
think about it alex is doing this too
yeah alex is starting yeah alex has
started consulting with i had the same
talk with alex i'm like alex as long as
nothing else falls as long as you can do
everything and this is like
on the side you do your thing what
this is really exciting you tell your
story first so i i just i thought of
something very forget it don't forget i
won't no no no no no no no you got to
say it now come on
somebody offered me uh
a consulting gig a one full day
experience where they can also shoot
content with me
for three thousand dollars
but then i countered at five
and they agree is
uh it's someone that had uh i don't his
name is cole and he's previously he did
the same exact thing with investment joy
long as you're legitimate yeah that's
that was exactly like if it's a crypto
channel or anything nope no it's real
estate
okay yeah all right so anyways that is
for me that's insane that's like crazy
money so i'm really excited about that
and basically would consist of six hours
of me doing like youtube consulting uh
and just like other random media
consulting as well yeah and
i think he also this person also wants
to shoot content with me so maybe do
like a podcast or something for their
podcast um and then that's it yeah but
that was like that was crazy exciting
for me nothing's ever happened like that
before that's pretty cool to hear yeah
so when are you gonna do that i think
it's coming next month yeah they're
paying half up front and a half after
yeah tell them for a fee i'll come to
your house too yeah just you know
yeah how much would you pay me to be on
the channel i got a va well i
i think a lot of it is just spending the
time together and some a lot of it is
the consulting yeah the video is a
byproduct of the
so jack's going to call me graham what
should i do what do you think about
these thumbnails yeah what do i do i
don't know i don't know which stuff
which one do you like just ask you
that's really exciting for me it's crazy
so i had uh yeah so like graham was
saying i started a company as well and i
started consulting and the way that this
came about
is you won't believe it i was looking to
furnish a cop sorry not a coffee a uh
dining table and chairs so i'm
scrambling facebook marketplace i'm
scrambling craigslist you know i'm
trying to pick one up on the low and um
i decided to go into creative gigs and
somebody was looking for like a
podcast guy like to set up to you know
to pick out equipment set it up and
stuff and um so i was like oh i should
um email this person and so i emailed
them and i didn't want them like to know
that i worked on the iced coffee hour
just because like i didn't want to
accidentally meet
like a fan like oh not that like it's
bad i just didn't want somebody to feel
like they should pick me solely because
i'm on the ice we also don't want the
liability if you're going and doing
something under the brand of the iced
coffee and someone slips and falls and
all of a sudden we get it i'm not
working under the iced coffee
so yeah so i so i sent them over my uh
my website my personal website and i was
like hey i'm a photographer but i've
also designed these sets and then i just
sent screenshots of our podcast my
video on my channel i took a screenshot
of my set and i just sent them over and
i was like um i just told them i had
experience producing
x
type of podcast and um so then i went
over met him downtown and i got a gig
and then ironically
like after this gig a lot of people hit
me up to do
podca the same exact thing just pure
coincidence perfect pure coincidence and
so all these like clients started coming
up and um i didn't know what to do so
because when i was doing the guide
downtown um i asked graham like graham
how much do you think i should charge
graham gave me like a really low number
and i thought it was wrong what was the
number he gave you he said alex
you should charge like 50 bucks an hour
is that what you said upset sounds like
what i would have said 50 to 100. you
know what probably now i'm starting to
think graham's incentivized to think
that my time is worth a certain amount
i'm just i'm just
oh sorry oh i swear i'm just messing
around
no no he was you know i hadn't you know
consulted much and stuff so it would
have been a good start but i threw out a
number because think about it i'm
editing so much i have so much stuff to
do i i said it had to be worth my time
so i just threw out a number out there
and uh it was a lot higher
than what graham suggested and uh sure
enough
got got the job so how much is it what's
really hard to say because you can't
really compare project to project
because some of the bigger clients that
that have come to be and i've already
done work for they have a much bigger
scope of project so
it's not a specific price per
but it depends on the project and
another thing that the clients have
asked for is reoccurring work so they
have a show or a podcast or videos that
they want to produce um and they want
somebody in the house to be able to go
make sure that they don't have any tech
issues make sure that the quality is up
to par and then edit and deliver a final
product
now that i definitely do not have time
for because even now um to scrape out
time away from what we're doing here on
the ice coffee hour and with graham um
it's already hard enough
i just don't have room for for work so
i'm thinking about getting a um editor
and producer to work with me and
what do you guys think objectively
because it seems like with most
businesses they do not allow you to do
work outside of the business because for
these reasons i guess it might take away
or might distract what are your guys i
know you're both biased on this and i'm
kind of like i honestly i'm right in the
middle where i like i see company's
point of views where it's like you just
do this this is your focus and we need
you on youtube i also see that like i
never want that to build resentment or
hold people back to the point where it's
like well i may as well just leave then
i think that that's a fair point to
bring up for a company um but i think
that that would be priced into a salary
so like if graham came up to me he's
like alex you know i know you have a lot
of work on i know it's not necessarily
impacting performance but i would feel
more comfortable if i knew you were
dedicated to this then i may bring up
okay well
there's a potential price to that you
know and and maybe you're willing to pay
the price because it's like
you know i don't want you to have any
distractions so um i think that there is
a a potential price to that but it also
is where does it limit you because um i
was talking to somebody who's a mutual
friend of all ours and you know he was
telling me that he had that in his uh
with his employer
but that limits him to even personal
projects so i think it depends on the
extent of it right because maybe
you know personal projects maybe are a
little bit different versus going out
and getting other clients so
i think it's a balance and it depends on
the relationship between the employer
and the employee and what what it all
entails i'm on the side by the way
working with ryan pineda on creator
properties what's that yeah so it's a
don't act like you haven't heard of
creator properties everyone should know
everyone's gonna create our properties
yeah go ahead tell us what it is yeah so
i got really hooked on uh when brandon
turner was here from bigger pockets uh
investing in his fund
and i have to say it was one of the
easiest smoothest transactions i've ever
done because i know how difficult it is
to be a landlord and i'm dealing with
crap right now believe it or not with
the tenant uh i issued uh an i want to
sell the property so i had to issue a
notice
and uh not leaving
yep
so uh yeah you're getting real tired of
that so yeah so anyway so after
uh investing in brandon's fun i loved
the experience so much and just having
it be passive uh that it just happened
to work out with ryan pineda that he has
these incredible properties that like i
would be investing into myself uh i
don't have the money obviously to come
up with like you know
six to
you know 12 million dollars to buy the
property outright for myself it just
doesn't make sense for the amount of
work so we've been doing uh funding for
it so basically if you're an accredited
investor you could go in and invest i
believe it's as little as 25 grand could
go all the way up depending on how much
you want to invest but uh it's been a
fantastic opportunity we have a deal in
phoenix by the way that's supposed to be
closing soon and we have a few extra
spots
in that phoenix deal and it's really
exciting because when you look at
historic rents
across the u.s they've consistently gone
up even during 2008 when the housing
market collapsed you see rental prices
and they stayed exactly the same it's
actually rather remarkable how robust
rents have been so when i look at these
properties i don't so much think like
what's the value i think what is the
rents going to be over the next 10 years
what
you just
it's remarkable how robust rents have
been true
you know what editing all of graham's
videos too um phoenix is actually very
low inventory yeah and uh it's one of
the places that that is skyrocketing as
well did you buy a place for like 11
million and i already got a praise for
15 or something that was the phoenix
deal yeah
already yeah
yeah so it's already under market uh
the the purchase price is 12.8 it got
appraised at 15.3 assuming a four
hundred thousand dollar renovation so
there's a lot of profit in there so if
you
said
are you buying in at the 50 million
dollar evaluation though no you're
buying into the
outside so it's lower
basically making money immediately
correct i mean you can't guarantee i
mean it's based off the appraisal right
so you can't say like guaranteed it's
going to be selling at that price on
that deal it just happened
yes but generally appraisals tend to be
somewhat conservative because the banks
are lending on these numbers so they
don't want to be immediately underwater
or be too ambitious so anyway if
anyone's interested i'll link to it down
below we do have a few spots left if you
want to be a part of it
creatorproperties.com and that's in the
description i i want to ask you jack we
got the volvo remember the ball with a
thousand dollars do i remember it
dude that was our first vlog yeah when i
first moved out here really that was the
first year so yeah so i got a question
for you the dogecoin millionaire came
over the other day yeah and he was
complaining about his car by the way
huge shout out to lucky automotive life
he's got a channel on youtube he's our
go-to car guy for everything the
dogecoin millionaire told me on my
channel he's like i want to buy a tesla
i said why do you want to buy a tesla
because my car doesn't have ac
it turned out and so after that i i told
them why are you looking to getting your
car fixed do you know what and he's like
no i haven't even checked it just
doesn't work
lucky said he fixed it for ten dollars
no way it was a fuse that was it
this guy has been driving around without
air conditioning for years
thinking it just doesn't work for ten
dollars on a fuse that lucky fits he
probably didn't even charge him for the
views i don't know if he did or not i
think he should have just for the
principle of it i mean it's like come on
for years that ac so anyway just as a
punishment
automotive life gets a huge thumbs up
here
i haven't had to use lucky but lucky
you're my go-to guy yeah he is and he
got jacks miata too yeah lucky's really
hooked all of us up so how about this
just go give him a follow what's it
lucky lopez after you guys finish
watching this video yeah sure lucky
lopez on instagram and just you could
send him a dm be like i heard about you
and the podcast bug them
you know anyway um i joked to the
dogecoin guy and i i said you could buy
the volvo because i don't we have too
many cars right now and they uh it's
just i don't know but i drive the car
and i said hey you know what if you if
you pay like market value for the card
consider it and then alex came up to me
and said well kelsey needs a car so i'm
like she start because she started
driving so my response to alex was why
don't you rent the car yeah he was
trying to get me to rent the lease the
car from him i thought it was going to
be able to do it
because because the thing is i drive
that car all the time i like the car a
lot and so it makes sense that kelsey
doesn't drive i asked how much calls you
drive twice a week why buy a car for
seven days when you could rent it for
two so now well i could probably just
borrow it for for free
yeah you definitely could i could just
take the keys and just
no because then there's an insurance
liability wear and tear on the cars
insurance liability
uh who is no it's because uh someone
didn't pay the registration jack someone
didn't pay the registration on not their
car oh
wasn't the registration to bring you up
to speed graham
uh gave me his credit card to book
insurance oh and i set it up but he
canceled that credit card without
telling us no i didn't cancel it i don't
know why it never sorry his bank
declined the transaction for whatever
reason yeah and obviously i don't have
access to the statements or anything i
don't even have access to the insurance
app yeah uh but uh anyway it lapsed and
now that's why we're giving apparently
so i got pulled over here so i found
this out i was driving and i saw a cop
behind me and i'm thinking i'm good like
i have nothing to worry about
everything's there's nothing illegal on
the car like some of the cars loud
exhaust or window tints and i'm sitting
there being like roll down the windows
and the cop was following me for a while
i'm like i just had a feeling i'm gonna
get pulled over sure enough uh light
turns green
get the lights coming up and i pull over
like what did i do wrong i was driving
perfectly he says that the registration
expired because apparently when you
don't
when you don't pay the registration on
that also the insur something else with
the insurance labs is something weird
happens in that so anyway got off with a
warning but uh yeah so it's just
nevada's weird like that i got a
speeding ticket
for like the first time since i was like
a teenager
for going between 11 and 19 miles over
so i log in online to to take a look
graham told me i should look into doing
class so it doesn't go on my thing and
so i log in and it gives me
automatically two options
um to like accept the
you know the da's or whatever
and the two options are i can either
take a class pay a hundred bucks sorry
pay 150 bucks for the ticket take a
class get no points on my license or
pay 150 bucks
and then pay a hundred dollar whatever
penalty and then
it gets reduced to a a non-moving
violation and no no class no points wow
so they don't care if you're a safer
driver you could just buy it
you could just buy yourself so anyway i
bought
of course you love that look at you but
for people like me no i'm just kidding
i felt a little weird i was like what if
you can't afford you can't afford it so
i felt a little bad then you do the the
school i know but then i was like but
there's still a cost to the school
probably like 50 bucks
i mean you shouldn't speed yeah i opted
in to take the school when i got my
ticket because it was cheaper but it was
good yeah i took school one time when i
was like 18 and my instructor was
talking about
how he had a hangover last night
he was still feeling a little
oh my god i was like this is like the
worst class to be in but oh my gosh yeah
so nevada's a little weird with that
stuff wow all right what do you think
about selling the car though what do you
think jack do it
you honestly i don't know why you have
it man you i thought you would tell me
to keep the car no i just i
it takes up space in your driveway and i
want to park there man cause alex and i
cannot be parked in your driveway well
if it's not that if it's not that it's
gonna be the tesla it's sitting there
all right keep it
in that case
it's gonna be a car sitting yeah i
wanted to buy it off of graham but i
could not justify because you know i
thought he was going to give me a good
you know off-market deals car you know
you know a little bit under marketplace
what would you offer me i told alex to
go and look up the fair market value of
the car graham's gonna come back and
then come back to me with an offer see i
i know what you paid for i picked it up
with jack but that was based on a
decade-long relationship uh building
close connections with friends
uh you don't know how much work i put
out how many how many dinners i had how
much work did you like
to get that car man
no i couldn't justify paying like market
value because here's the thing i said
make me an offer mark there's market
value and then there's an offer i
offered you like 2k no i'm not going to
negotiate this out right now what is the
car tell us the specs it's a 2 000.
yeah you know what how about this how
about this i could also offer it to the
audience if you want to buy the volvo
don't do that no it's it's a bidding one
no that's just more competition no guys
if you like me please don't send me let
me just explain what the car is it's a
2006 volvo s60 leather seats 112 000
miles on it runs like a champ
cold ac burns oil it doesn't burn oil
okay the oil was low once the door
doesn't open yeah it does you got to put
the key in it doesn't open
the key in there
that the launcher must have trouble
opening it it has difficulty but you
just have to open it up with a key it's
not that big of a deal it's not that big
of a deal so anyway it runs like a champ
does not burn oil needs the ac recharge
no it doesn't i i drive with the ac on
it's fine anyway um
i'm guessing the fair market value is
probably somewhere between five and
sixty five hundred bucks
that's probably the fair market value
hundred and twelve thousand miles
i just couldn't that sounds like like on
the kelly blue book thing you know has
this that's how i looked at that that
sounds like a little bit on the higher
yeah it looks like a little bit on the
green
the condition is good you don't need a
kelly blue book your volvo right now
this is just
okay oh i'm taking it seriously you know
i i thought it was a great opportunity
to buy a like a good affordable used car
for kelsey but we're saving up for a
house i'm trying to cut back on my
spending
and you know realistically unless i got
a deal that i couldn't pass up on i i'm
not going to take it because that's
another insurance payment you know how
much did you pay for it
i'd rather not say why
well i got a good deal
no because i know i got a good deal in
the car and i don't want that to imagine
the selling price right that's your
thing yeah yeah you're good
but i don't want that to impact the
sales price because people know uh the
the purchase price and the sales price
they're going to do the math yeah and
they're going to we're making more money
they're going gonna think we're making
more money talking about they're gonna
think that maybe i have more wiggle room
than i really do
if anything here's the deal i i like
even if even if someone came to me right
now said here's market value for the car
i wouldn't sell it so you're not even
planning on selling it no but i don't
know when she bought it it no but the
thing is i would sell it to alex or the
dogecoin millionaire because i know them
and it would make me feel good to have
that car go to someone i know but if
someone came and offered me the 6 500
bucks right now for the car i'd say no
because i get more use out of it like i
calculate every time i take that card
down at the strip or like do something
with the car i think what would an uber
cost me because i don't want to put
miles on the ford gt or like anything
what would an uber it's a 40 bucks so i
calculate you know that's forty dollars
so i don't subtract that you know what
someone gave you 6 500 for that volvo
you would spend 4 500 on a nicer car so
here's the deal if someone came to me
and says here's 12 000 i want to make a
video saying i bought graham stefan's
volvo all appear in the video they buy
the car for 12 grand i don't think
knowing the price that you paid for that
car would affect that decision okay so
so let me ask you this jack what uh your
parents when did they buy their their
home what are they what was the original
price of that home
2002. see that how much they pay for
that i don't think i should say oh
oh i see this is not my thing oh okay so
do you think that sellers look at your
parents home and don't offer it based
off market value they offer based on
what they paid for the home they offered
certainly off of market value exactly so
same with the car it doesn't matter what
i paid it matters what the market value
is think of uh you know so that's why
it's someone the reason why i'll say how
much i bought my house for it i have no
problem so i'm not gonna say someone
else's personal financial information
but my point being is that it doesn't
matter based on uh you know for an offer
i just i don't want that to impact the
value someone offers you know like if i
if i knew you bought a board ape what to
say
just to say how much that's on the block
you bought it you bought a board ape for
you know let's just say a thousand
dollars that's on the block thousand
i'm just saying i'm just saying if jack
bought a board for a thousand dollars
and the market values two hundred
thousand sixty-five
you know
i'm just saying it doesn't matter
someone's also willing to offer your
thing for content but your but your
point is that graham it doesn't matter
because you're making a profit off the
car and my point is there's a market
value for that i want i want i wouldn't
sell it at market value but if someone
came to me at twelve thousand i'm gonna
pump the value of volvo s60s right now
listen they're a great car i think
they're going they're going up in price
they're good investment now
i'm just saying 12 grand if you want to
come here do do a video with the car uh
i'll say the car now there's no warranty
it's as is you could do an inspection on
the car no well every car sales you know
i sold uh a ford explorer pleaded not my
first ever car i sold it i i
i got 2200 for this car
and uh it's obviously as is the guy
takes it an hour later yo man the car
broke down on the side of the freeway
i'm here got towed to my buddy's house
and i was like i've driven this car
throughout high school like this car was
perfect never an issue i said okay tell
tell me you know what happened when
you're at your body stuff the body
caught hey man so i run the shop here
you sold my buddy a lemon man like this
needs work this needs work it's going to
be like 700 bucks and then the guy comes
back on the phone yo man i can't pay for
this i just bought this car yo could you
at least just like you know pay for the
700 bucks we'll fix it
and i was like this feels so sketch
because what are the chances he buys
this car that i've been driving for
years and within 20 minutes it breaks i
looked online and apparently it's a
common scam that people who buy cars
like that pull at your heart strings and
then get more money out of you because
it broke down the car yeah yeah or they
just pocket the money like they're
friends with a guy at the shop
yeah yeah and then they get an extra 700
bucks maybe they split at 50 50. so i
just called nate you know as is oh oh
this guy knew where i lived and got like
really scary on the phone too when i
told him no he kept calling kept calling
kept calling and he left me a voicemail
i was like yo i know where you live i'm
gonna come there and like f you up you
don't know who you're dealing with man
and he was like he said he was like a
part of some like gang or something like
that like he was from east l.a and like
and he had my dress because he was on
yeah it was it was i don't know it
wasn't on the title but it was on like
the bill of sale it was something like
that he he knew where i lived so anyway
i got home and it was just me at the
it's just me there and i was so scared
like walking up and um
i don't think i had a knife i basically
ran through the front door and then i
had a i went to the kitchen i grabbed a
knife and then i slept with a knife and
that night there was an earthquake
and i woke up out of my sleep having a
dream that he was shaking me while there
was an earthquake
that sounds like yeah
it was so scary
so anyway and that nothing came from it
so yeah they were probably just trying
to scam you most likely and you probably
saw i was i was 19 or 18 at probably 19
at the time so you probably saw a young
kid i saw you at 18 19 show me a picture
yeah you look like a youngster yeah i
definitely would would yeah lose you
look like the type of guy that would
send me seven hundred dollars
no offense but yeah
and he met me outside of uh one of my
listings in beverly hills so that
definitely did not help let's talk about
something that's going to change the
history of this channel potentially
forever i want to see it logo designs
yeah
so we're taking submissions or we took
submissions yeah alex is going to show
us we're going to figure out what the
logo is going to be for the podcast yeah
and you know what we could bring in
spencer and andre
get their thoughts and logos
no they're getting here shortly oh okay
yeah let's get it all right let me let
me plug this up let's get it let's go
let's get it oh great fine sorry all
right fine sorry
welcome back to the millennial money pod
iced coffee hour today it's just a long
one flip it flip it around we have
something extremely exciting everybody
so we have a new profile photo and a new
logo design for the entire brand of the
iced coffee hour we took submissions and
now we have both andre and spencer in
the house say what's up spencer hello
hello so yeah we're gonna be picking out
the new profile photo they just decided
to show up for millennial money so it's
perfect we have multiple opinions let's
see the logo can help us all right let's
see the first one all right guys so
first um i just want to say i put this
together not too long before this so uh
excuses
no no no no not excuses so uh
here's the first one so this was
submitted by dario russell that's
correct okay so it's hard to see but he
came up with a few different concepts
um let's see if we could get them in
here now i love that absolutely
top middle is sweet i love the top
middle balloon
really good and the center ones yeah
middle one's cool too the middle one is
my favorite so my favorite one out of
these is uh the
oh
all right i like the bottom that's my
favorite so far is the bottom one so but
i do like the top one too looks kind of
like a milkshake doesn't it yeah so so
it's good that was darian russell so
let's or sorry darren russell so thank
you for submitting darren um let's go
ahead and move on down to the next one
here so next one is by bryce betts uh so
we know bryce but uh try to be unbiased
here all right and here are his
submissions a little more playful a
little more fun but
now my favorite one is the uh
the middle bottom right yep my two yup
you guys coffee hour or the funny words
yep i think that one's awesome i like
the little cartoons but i like the word
the simplicity of the words yeah it's
interesting that cartoon would be a good
character you know yeah everyone is like
a man yeah like a mascot paper clip
shows up
what do you think spencer you got some
how important are the words
to the branding like the words of the
podcast
because that might differentiate right
from the start of the ones that have
the podcast name versus the ones that
don't i don't i think words are pretty
important but then again the other one
didn't have any words and we like you
can always implement words as well with
a design yeah um the top right is my
favorite one in this group right there i
think it's really good it's really
obvious what the podcast is
you know what would be interesting if we
get rid of the with gram and jack just
the iced coffee hour with the green
get rid of anger
all right so i actually like the top one
uh i i like the green the best actually
wow the top one it does without the with
grandma jack
just graham yeah okay dude these are
good logos
all right moving on i tried to pick up a
variety here
so next is george alatour could be jorge
jorge
all right guys so here he actually
incorporated waveforms with line charts
and on the right waveforms with uh
candlesticks oh my gosh that's so good
so these are the the um the ones with
the charts here yeah and these are the
ones where you took inspiration from
candles really cool so that's cool i
like that yeah oh gosh they're so good
all right let's keep them moving that
would be a great banner but we already
have a release yes
oh look he made uh he made this too here
so here's the back oh my look it says
sometimes alex that okay so
alex is like can you edit that in so you
notice though a little circle there you
can't see what it says the iced coffee
hour if that were redone i don't know
how do we do the candlesticks in a
little tiny
circle that'd be my concern there's a
lot of detail in some thumbnails it's
simplicity i know what i love about this
is you can clearly see yes the
and i believe he put together a mock up
here oh that's cool and he made a banner
too you know what i kind of like the
green i feel like green with the money
symbol stands out a little bit what do
you think about adding the logo that
cool logo that you guys liked in the
first part to the eye and iced
because that would be a natural
that might be kind of possibility
here we go look at this one guys that's
a nice one
i think it's a pretty clean design for
sure
i like the other one better i like it
yeah i like that one you guys like what
do you think what do you think
um i like the first and the other one a
little bit better yeah i'm a fan of the
more modern like look yeah but i wanted
to choose a variety of logos and i
thought this one was very well designed
as well yeah that would make a great
neon sign wouldn't it yeah that i would
imagine
all right let's see what we got going on
here craig o'neil there you go you got
two renditions wow
it looks like very simple tacks and just
some drips so i worry it's a small image
it's hard to it's also very horizontal
so the profile photo is circular one
recommendation do you guys
buy these and post them in the room i
think that would be super dope that
would be kind of cool just a nice
decoration i think it would add some
personality in here that's cool all
right let's see antonio de vico that's
cool that's really i like that one i
wonder if we just did the green
background instead of the black ooh
that's right i like that i think this is
nice simple it's got some design
elements for sure yeah what do you think
andre it's really pretty is that your
favorite or what do you think still the
other one i think you could use elements
of some of the ones we really liked for
different things i i don't think i could
pick just one yeah i know that's how i
feel about dating
all right so we got we could have them
all spencer how do you pick just one we
got chris hensley he sent over a few
like three so let's take a look here
okay here's the first one
nice coffee hour that's really good oh
look at these these were great i like
those that's cool
wow and uh
yeah i think that's the last one oh man
i honestly feel honored that people made
this mistake they're all yeah the thing
is if we had just one of these they
would all be good let us know down below
in the uh the comments what i don't know
if i could pick i'd have to look
handpicked it's going to take 30 minutes
to go through them again and like very
strategic about it yeah
let us know down below in the comments
which one is your favorite just be very
specific and say i like this one from
this person like the third one from the
right just be specific about it and
we'll read we'll see which one people
like the best it's got to be visible
though and a little tiny image a little
circle so keep that in mind it's got to
be easily uh seen are we going to allow
the goldfish to pick that's not a bad
idea it's never wrong and it's never
wrong thank you guys for tuning in we
really appreciate it thank you andre
thank you spencer
you guys for getting a free stock down
below in the description when you sign
up for public interviews
photography until next time
cool
thanks guys